hi my name is greg alpa and i'm john
humphrey and we are the real rejects hi
uh thank you so much for taking the time
to talk with us you were like freaking
awesome in this movie
you were like so damn good and really
timeless you're way more talented than
us in every single way and it's not
intimidating at all for someone at your
age
but um i know we only got a short amount
of time so i just kind of want to dive
right into it i wanted to ask a common
practice for actors is creating the
backstory and memories of the character
however your character is like thousands
of years old so it's almost like a near
impossible task so i'm curious how did
you go about crafting backstory for
sprite did you do any memory building
exercises in conjunction with chloe zhao
or like any of the other cast
well
if you see the movie you know that it
sort of goes back and forth throughout
time and shows some little moments and a
lot of the flashbacks didn't make it
into the final cut of the movie and i
think
shooting those scenes definitely helped
to build to like the future day i
usually just try my best to understand
the character and why she's feeling a
certain way and um chloe really helped
me with that i
i try to stay in the moment and find
connection with the other actors around
me that makes a lot of sense i thought
you did a great job with that absolutely
and uh you know your character is the
same age as the rest of the characters
in the eternals but you know in real
life you're a teenager and then you're
also having to behave like a you know
aged adult uh were you ever intimidated
about having to share the screen with
you know a bunch of veteran actors who
you know do have that life experience
i mean
working with adults is always like it
always gives me something to you know
live up to it's a certain standard let
alone you know this a-list cast that i'm
working i've worked with um it's really
interesting to see how everyone works
and i found
a lot of inspiration from
you know their work ethic and the way
that they did things that made me want
to perform better
oh that sounds cool so it sounds like a
real uplifting experience yes it was
great i mean it was a little
intimidating at first but i went into it
not like super duper aware of how a-list
these actors were
okay so i think that was definitely
helpful because i wasn't i mean i was
really only nervous to meet richard
madden honestly i really like richard
understandably so understandable i was
such a big fan of him oh my gosh
cinderella but
besides him i think i was just really
excited to be part of the film and meet
chloe and to be able to portray this
character i mean i was excited to go to
work every day
that's awesome to hear i i mean i just
have to ask this uh because it's within
the mcu
which mcu character like outside of
eternals would you love most to possibly
do just a really
damn good scene with
i mean
my favorite some of my favorite
characters
i think
i love thorin loki and i love their
banter and i love their relationship i
mean i would love to work with tom
hiddleston oh my god i like i think
loki's just so funny and like such a
great character um but because he's sort
of gone
um i think my second choice would be
thor i love him i think he's great i
actually got to meet them and i
absolutely freaked out did you meet them
when did you meet them at comic-con
oh yeah from from a while back wow a
while back two years actually thinking
about sprite and loki would be a really
good one
especially with the kind of power sets
that you guys have that would be perfect
a lot of comparison of our characters
anyway so
oh yeah well i hope it does come true um
but i know you've been like so busy and
i really appreciate you taking the time
uh to speak with us i know we gotta rap
right now but seriously uh you did such
an excellent job and uh it was we were
you were as on par with all the eight
listers you were just on equal level the
whole time and we mean that sincerely
yeah very impressive so uh enjoy uh the
celebration over the next few weeks
because i will
all right thank you
[Music]